it's always exciting sometimes there's
even between the workmen
a bit of a competition who will find
first
while conservators move the painted
walls to the storerooms for safe keeping
tarek spots something in the sand
we have a pillar
and i can see already there is a jet
pillar
decorated on it
it's an important find
this pillar confirms the nature of
ancient egyptian religious beliefs
in the years after the armani revolution
and tutankhamun's death
[Music]
this is exciting the disease is
appearing now
as he would have been carrying the jet
killer
the jed symbol represents the god osiris
who arose from the dead to live again as
king of the afterlife
ancient egyptians painted the symbol on
the bottom of coffins
and wrapped the mummy with jed amulets
to summon osiris and rejuvenate the soul
of the deceased
they also carved jed symbols onto the
pillars in their tombs
to follow osiris to the afterlife
[Music]
in the time of amanda
they told them that there is no
afterlife
after there was a reaction
the extreme worshipping osiris
the team has found inscriptions to
osiris and tower
gods whose worship tutankhamun's father
had forbidden
it's more evidence tutankhamun had
abandoned his father's revolution
he had restored belief in the afterlife
and the power of all egypt's gods
the religious revolution demanding the
worship of a single sun god
was over
this was a feat that deserved a
magnificent burial and a majestic tomb
[Music]
so why didn't tutankhamun's mummy get
the tomb it deserved
[Music]
in the valley of the kings
aliyah is investigating this mystery
why does i
banish tutankhamun to such a small and
poorly decorated tomb
aaliyah examines eye's tomb to look for
clues
that's the baboon wall
both todd and i
opted for the same scene almost like the
same person shows what goes in each tune
[Music]
the uncanny similarities between the two
chambers suggests a common hand was at
work on both
but only i's tomb was fit for a pharaoh
it's very similar to the tomb of
tutankhamun the style the artwork the
sarcophagus
but it's so much bigger
the artistic style of the two tombs
suggests that i may have been
responsible for decorating both
investigators now suspect that when
tutankhamun died unexpectedly young the
lavish tomb he ordered for himself was
not finished
i seized the moment
he ordered tut be buried in a smaller
tomb
it was quickly decorated and sealed
before the paint had a chance to dry
with tutankhamun gone and before any
challenges could oppose him i crowned
himself pharaoh and decreed that when he
died
he would take tutankhamun's tomb
[Music]
i bear to uncommon in the smaller tomb
so
he could have the bigger tomb for
himself
this is the tomb that was intended for
tutankhamun the tomb of i
i banished tutankhamun to an unworthy
tomb to secure his place as pharaoh
later pharaohs erased tutankhamun from
history
smearing his name as the son of a
heretic
but one hundred years ago when his tomb
was discovered
tutankhamun was reborn a superstar
now experts use the clues to piece
together his true legacy
[Music]
as a boy king dealing with the aftermath
of his father's religious revolution
[Music]
you